(bright music)
- Welcome back here to
another episode on my channel,
Firm Learning, welcome
to another coffee break.
As you can see,
today's video is going
to be a bit different.
It's a Sunday here in Munich,
sitting on my balcony,
enjoying a nice brunch
with a couple of friends.
And indeed, today,
I'm just going to guide
you through the day
and the highlight of today
is going to be a meetup.
The very first Firm
Learning meetup is happening
in a beer garden here in Munich.
And if you didn't know about that,
that's probably because you
don't follow me on Instagram
where I do these kinds of announcements,
So follow me to stay up to date for that.
Trust, it's going to be some
great impressions later today
that we are going to see.
Next to me, I have Paul
with me here today.
Paul is the co-founder of Building Radar,
one of my colleagues,
who we recently had a
couple of MBA students
visiting us in Munich at our
office at Building Radar.
And we just had a discussion with them
what's it like to found a business,
what's it like to found a startup,
and actually I thought that you made
a couple of very great
points on what's that like,
some pointers to guide
people for their decision.
Would you mind just sharing your thoughts
on this topic here?
- First, thanks, Heinrich,
for the great breakfast here.
It was really nice to sit here in the sun.
And yeah, so basically, with the students,
we were discussing whether it makes sense
to first get some work
experience in a proper company
because that obviously can help you
when you deal with professionals
in your startup life.
And on the other hand, it's all about,
I mean founding a company
is all about risk-taking,
and we were basically
discussing the pros and cons
of starting a business
right out of university
or maybe first giving it
one, two, three years in,
for example, management consulting
because you can also learn a
lot about different industries.
In my opinion,
which is obviously biased
by my own experience,
is I would always try to do
it right out of university
because you basically
have nothing to lose,
like you are used to a very
basic standard of living
and worst case, you can
still just get a job
after six months if your business fails.
And I think that was a pretty
interesting discussion there.
(bright music)
- So we're done with the
brunch now, our friends left.
We just tidied up the
apartment a little bit.
We had three little kids here
so it was a little bit messy indeed.
But now, we have the time
to film a couple of TikToks.
So recently, tried to step up
my TikTok game a little bit,
we'll also insert the social
somewhere here, check it out.
Nicholas, my videographer,
is here as well,
who will now help me with that.
So let's get into it.
It is so important to do that right,
make sure you follow these crucial steps.
I wanna share three key tips
that I believe will really
make the difference for you.
First, you need to have strong academics,
so make sure you have good
GPAs, done lots of internships,
and this will then help
significantly to get that done.
(bright music continues)
So we just filmed a
couple of takes at home
and thought it might be great idea
to also make use of the nice
scenery, the nice weather.
So now, we moved here to the Isar,
just to create a couple
of additional TikToks
so let's do that right now,
and then afterwards, we'll go
to the Firm Learning meet up,
very excited to meet many
of you there as well.
How much do you save every month?
Is it 10% of your annual income?
To build wealth in a significant.
What always surprises
me are business students
who spent their whole bachelor.
(bright music continues)
So we just created a couple
of additional TikToks
here at the Isar.
Next to me is actually Nicholas,
so this is my videographer,
so he is responsible for some
of the Firm Learning videos
that you've seen over the last months.
So thanks, Nicholas,
really for all your work,
that's much appreciated.
And yeah, so let's move
back to our apartment
and then let's see what we do next,
probably sooner moving toward the meetup,
very much looking forward to that.
(bright music continues)
So we are on our way to the meetup now,
just did a little pit stop at home.
Very much looking forward to it,
so a couple of you already
texted me you can do it,
some others told me, no
they can't do it, and so on,
so let's see how many of you are there.
If you've missed it again,
these are things I
announce on my Instagram.
So follow me there to stay up to date.
I'm here with my wife and our baby girl.
By the way, we are expecting
now our second child,
it will come likely in November.
The doctor didn't really know yet
whether it was going to be
a baby girl or baby boy,
likely a boy, but let's see.
Very excited to meet all of you,
let's see us there and all the best.
So now we're here, this
the Augustiner-Keller,
it's one of the well-known
beer gardens here in Munich.
This is why I invited
you here for the meet up.
Looking forward to that, let's go in
and let's see our many of you are here,
very, very excited to meet all of you.
(upbeat music)
That's Helles, yeah?
But I think the more fun approach
just to do whatever you like, right?
(upbeat music continues)
So thanks for all of you joining,
it's really a pleasure
that all of you are here.
It's really the very first time
I'm doing anything comparable
to this, to such a meet up.
Usually, maybe I get some
messages from you on Instagram
on LinkedIn or per email or whatever,
and then I can text with some of you
and that's already a pleasure as well
but seeing all of you
here, right now, today,
here in the beer garden,
that's really, really cool.
I hope you are enjoying yourself as well.
Maybe getting to know some new people,
I talked to many of you already,
I think lots of very ambitious
professionals or students.
So great that I meet all of you.
So how did I start Firm Learning?
Because this is something
that also some of you asked me now today.
It was early 2020 and I
was just out of consulting,
and as you know, it's not a myth, right?
But in consulting, you
have rather long hours.
So suddenly I didn't have all
this work in the evenings,
I had a bit more time.
And then I was sitting at home.
I think my wife just left,
but I was talking to my wife.
Okay, what do I do with
all my evenings now, right?
What do I do with my time?
Of course, then the new position,
it was not like it was a nine to five.
But surely it wasn't like
a nine to 12 or something.
So lots of time in the evening.
And I was already starting in this trap,
I was now watching Netflix
episodes in the evening,
just relaxing at home.
And that's fun of course,
but I didn't feel like
that was the end game
to do that every day.
And then I talked to my wife,
what about starting a YouTube channel?
Wouldn't that be a great idea?
And then my wife told me again, like,
unfortunately she just left,
but she would confirm, right?
She would tell me like, "Are you crazy?
Like, starting a YouTube channel,
who's doing that?"
And obviously, she was afraid
that everybody would
make fun of me and so on.
And I think a lot of people
also did make fun of me,
like in the first months
after I started the videos.
I mean, as you can imagine,
starting a YouTube channel,
of course, people talk, whatever.
The more thankful I am that right now,
I think the Firm Learning platform
is a platform that brings together people,
all of you are here now,
it's really something
that makes me super happy,
super proud that all of you are here,
we are enjoying this time together.
So thank you for that.
Let's all raise our glasses,
I think, to a good afternoon.
Thank you and cheers.
Great that you're all here, thanks.
(upbeat music)
I mean, always best to ask.
Which is also why.
So hope you enjoyed all these impressions
from the very first Firm Learning meet up.
For me, it's for sure still
something very special
to see how many people came here
to get to know my audience,
it's a great pleasure.
And as always, if you liked it,
leave a like, subscribe to the channel,
big, big, thanks to all the
members for checking this out.
I'm going to be back next week,
next Saturday with the next video.
All the best to you, my name is Heinrich,
releasing weekly content here
on Firm Learning, and bye-bye.